Traductor: Larisa Esteche
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Cuándo fue la última vez
que tuvieron una crisis?
¿Fue hoy?
¿Hace algunas horas, hace algunos días?
¿Hace algunos meses?
Quizás alguno de Uds. está teniendo
una crisis en este momento.
¿Pero cuándo fue la última vez
que disfrutaron de una crisis?
Que la sintieron, que la vivieron,
e inclusive estuvieron agradecidos
por tenerla.
Es una pregunta difícil, ¿verdad?
Y es que, ¿quién disfruta las crisis?
Pero, ¿qué pasaría si les dijera
que podríamos cambiar
esos momentos de crisis en obras de arte?
En verdaderas obras de arte.
Les dejo la idea en la cabeza.
Cuando tenía 0 horas,
0 minutos, y algunos segundos
en esta vida, comencé a presenciar
sin darme cuenta
una de las mayores crisis
que impactaron en mi vida
hasta el día de hoy.
Y es que mi llegada a este mundo
desencadenó, difícil hablar de esto,
desencadenó una enfermedad autoinmune
en una de las personas más importantes
para mí en este mundo: mi madre.
Durante los últimos 32 años,
vi a mi madre sufrir con las crisis
gracias a una enfermedad
que no la permitió cargarme en brazos.
Y quizá le costó mil veces más esfuerzo
que a cualquier otra persona
el tener una vida normal,
y que durante 32 años
no la permitió estar
un solo día sin dolor.
Pero si digo que esto me impactó
no solo fue por ver
la cantidad de sufrimiento
que una sola persona puede soportar.
Sino por ver que a pesar
de todos estos momentos
de angustia, de dolor y de crisis,
hoy mi madre es una mujer exitosa.
De hecho, la mujer más fuerte que conozco
y de hecho está acá, en esta audiencia,
siempre con una sonrisa
y con la mejor actitud.
Pero si hoy les cuento esto,
es porque cuando armaba esta charla
me proponía contar
estas pequeñas crisis que tuve
a lo largo de mi vida de emprendedor.
Estos momentos de angustia
parecían ser realmente nada
con lo que tienen que vivir
muchísimas personas en la vida.
Pero también me di cuenta
que estas crisis duelen
e incomodan igual.
Que no hay tal cosa
como demasiado pequeñas
pero tampoco las existen
demasiado grandes.
Y que sean del tamaño que sean,
no está mal, todas las crisis duelen igual
y no está mal sentirnos mal.
Pero lo que sucede después
y lo que hacemos con ellas
depende de cada uno.
Hace 11 años decidí
tomar uno de los caminos
más inciertos, atemorizantes,
ingratos, llenos de crisis,
el ser un emprendedor.
Y es que ese aire de aventura,
de crear, de impactar
y de construir las cosas
y pensar que podemos cambiar el mundo
a nuestro estilo era y es
algo demasiado adictivo.
Volviendo un poco más atrás,
yo recuerdo que a mis 17 años
salía de uno de los colegios
más prestigiosos de mi ciudad,
famoso por crear grandes ingenieros,
intelectuales e inclusive presidentes.
En mi mente, yo tenía la idea
y el camino estructurado,
de seguir una vida
y un camino estructurado.
De hecho, recuerdo que había sido aceptado
por una universidad en Chile,
a la cual tenía muchísimas ganas de ir
y de ser un ingeniero,
con maestrías y todo eso,
y sentía que mi camino estructurado
se hacía realidad.
De hecho, ya había sido aceptado
en esta universidad en Chile
y sentía que esos sueños
de adolescente se me hacían realidad.
Pero como el mundo da vueltas
y es que siempre lo hace,
mi mundo estructurado casi se cae
cuando por diferentes motivos
tuve que quedarme a estudiar localmente.
Y entré en crisis, ¿pero se dan cuenta
del tamaño de la crisis de ese momento?
De hecho me da vergüenza
hablar de esa crisis estando parado acá.
Pero me dolía igual.
Era una crisis igual.
Y en medio de toda esa crisis
me puse a pensar cuáles eran las cosas
que había perdido
al no salir a estudiar afuera,
pero también me puse a analizar
cuáles eran esas cosas
las cuales solamente yo
podía tomar una decisión,
y las cuales mis decisiones
podían cambiar el curso de mi historia.
Y decidí emprender.
Y esta decisión, de hecho
trajo una recompensa bastante pronto,
la de encontrar a un amigo
y a mi socio, una persona tan loca como yo
con quien compartimos, de hecho,
esas ganas locas de cambiar el mundo
y con quien hacemos negocios hasta hoy.
De hecho, recuerdo que nuestra primera
gran idea que tuvimos como emprendedores
hace 11 años fue hacer cinturones,
cinturones de tela,
y de verdad quién piensa
hacer cinturones de tela
como primer negocio, pero bueno.
No teníamos idea de nada,
solo queríamos crear y construir.
Y nos hubieran visto a los dos
días y días cociendo metros y metros
de cinta, puliendo cada hebilla
que sacábamos y cuidando la calidad
de cada cinturón que sacábamos.
Yo en mi vida había agarrado una aguja,
pero estábamos ahí
construyendo nuestro imperio.
Obviamente, este negocio
no fue a ningún lado, era malísimo.
Y de hecho tenemos cientos y cientos
de cinturones guardados en algún cajón.
Pero lo que más aprendí
de esta primera etapa
y de estas primeras crisis
fueron dos cosas.
Uno: que muchas veces
"crisis" significa tomar decisiones.
Y que si esas decisiones
las hacemos con lo que tenemos dentro,
llámalo intuición, corazón,
sexto sentido o lo que sea,
esas decisiones realmente
pueden cambiarles la vida.
Dos: y si no creen
que lo que están haciendo
puede ser realmente grande,
entonces su decisión o no fue tan buena,
o no la hicieron con el corazón.
Y les aseguro que en ese momento,
están encendiendo la mecha
para una crisis todavía mayor.
Luego de un tiempo,
ya habíamos descartado la idea
de ser emprendedores textiles
y nos dedicamos a hacer negocio
o empresa en algo que de alguna manera
entendíamos y algo que nos gustaba,
la tecnología.
En ese punto ya habíamos fundado
nuestra primera empresa,
que era un estudio web
bastante tradicional,
que de hecho lo fundamos
con los 150 dólares
de nuestro primer cliente.
Luego, cerramos esta empresa
para fundar la segunda empresa
que era un negocio, una plataforma
basada netamente en internet,
donde aparentemente íbamos encaminados
al éxito y aparentemente la empresa
tenía mucho potencial financiero.
De hecho, recuerdo que entre algunos
de los socios decidimos mudarnos
a San Francisco, California, y vivíamos
en pleno centro, en pleno corazón
de Silicon Valley.
Vivíamos a solo dos cuadras de PayPal,
íbamos a los bares de Stanford,
nos rodeábamos de gente de Google,
interactuábamos cada día con gente
que construía cosas increíbles.
Y a pesar de que todos los días
comíamos chili con carne de un dólar,
o dormíamos en alfombras,
o en colchones inflables,
estábamos bien, nos sentíamos bien
y no había crisis alguna.
Realmente estábamos cumpliendo el sueño
de cualquier emprendedor tech.
Nuestro paso por San Francisco
nos aseguraba una inversión en Chile.
De hecho, en una reunión con los socios
decidimos que yo sería quien iría
a representar a la empresa allá,
y cómo es la vida,
un tiempo después de esta primera
crisis de colegio, hacía mis maletas
y empezaba mi nueva vida en Santiago.
En Chile quizá fue uno de los momentos
en los que más trabajé en mi vida.
Como empresa teníamos
una gran oportunidad,
teníamos inversión y todo
lo que los emprendedores buscamos.
Como emprendedor, estaba en el lugar
donde sucedían las cosas.
Realmente me sentía en la cima,
no me podía perder nada.
Pero en medio de todo este trajín
e intensidad, en medio de estas charlas
con inversionistas y con emprendedores,
y despertarse o desvelarse
noches y noches pensando
cómo hacer la idea del millón,
muchas veces demasiado exagerada
creo yo, algo empezó a cambiar,
algo estaba mal.
Y es que esas ganas e inspiración
con la que habíamos comenzado
muchísimo tiempo atrás,
cuando empezamos a hacer cinturones
ya no estaban más.
Inclusive cosas tan triviales
como el dinero no me consolaron.
Y de hecho, si yo les muestro
y les comparo mi vida
en ese punto a cuando era un emprendedor
sin un peso, podrían darse cuenta
que mis momentos de inspiración
eran inversamente proporcionales
a la cantidad de dólares en el banco.
Y esto me sirvió para darme cuenta
que había encendido una mecha
muchísimo mayor hace algún tiempo atrás,
y estaba a punto de explotar.
Y explotó.
Explotó porque yo sentía
y yo sabía que mi pasión
y mi porqué era emprender,
pero en ese momento,
mi producto como emprendedor
no iba de la mano
con mi porqué como persona.
Y caí, y caí muy fuerte.
Caí tan fuerte que me encontré
en la peor crisis intelectual,
emocional, espiritual e inclusive,
perdón, inclusive espiritual de mi vida.
Había dejado la empresa
que me había tomado muchísimo,
los últimos cuatro años en construir,
la había dejado porque sentía
que no tenía un porqué,
un porqué claro.
Para sumar problemas,
la mujer con la que quería estar
ya no quería estar conmigo
porque pensaba que había perdido
mi rumbo hace mucho tiempo atrás.
Siendo un emprendedor,
no tenía ahorros, no tenía sueldo,
no tenía beneficios, los pocos ahorros
que tenía o estaban invertidos
en la empresa que acababa de dejar,
o se me acabaron.
Viviendo en un país
bastante caro en ese momento
para mí que era Chile,
el alquiler se me hizo impagable.
Y si bien siempre supe
que puedo contar con el apoyo
de mi familia,
sentía que tenía que vivir
esta crisis solo.
Recuerdo que un tiempo después,
como no podía pagar el alquiler,
esto seguramente no sabe mi madre,
pero tuve que ir a vivir
al sillón de un amigo,
al sillón de un amigo, tal cual,
un gran amigo que me abrió
las puertas de su casa
para darme un techo, un sillón claramente,
pero también para intentar
darme la energía que necesitaba
para sentirme inspirado y crear de nuevo.
En ese momento, mi mente era intocable.
Y me llovían recuerdos de dolor,
de ansiedades, de malestares,
y de crisis que había decidido parchar.
Muchas de esas noches
desembocaban en depresión, ira,
y sentimientos que realmente no tenía,
no había sentido nunca así,
nunca antes en mi vida.
Muchas de esas noches
desembocaban en llantos,
en lágrimas y una que otra
visita al bar.
Pero en medio de toda esta tormenta
y toda esta crisis tan grande,
algo dentro de mí se sintió
realmente cansado de esta situación.
Y me di cuenta de que la única manera
de salir de esta situación
que se apoderaba de mí
y era parte de mi vida,
no era intentando rechazar,
tapar y esconder
lo que sabía dentro de mí
que era verdad.
Sentía que si quería cambiar
y hacer realmente cambios en mi vida,
estos cambios deberían ser transversales.
Ya que si solamente
me dedicaba a cambiar algunas partes
que me incomodaban, mi rutina
y la forma en la que me había acostumbrado
a vivir me arrastrarían al mismo agujero.
Fue en ese momento cuando decidí aceptar,
abrazar y agradecer la crisis.
Y lo digo de nuevo, decidí aceptar,
Y en ese momento fue algo casi mágico,
porque dentro de mí,
dentro de mi cabeza, de mi cuerpo
y de mi alma decidí despertar
un millón de nuevas sensaciones
que tenían sabor a oportunidad.
Recuerdo que en este punto
iba a... hacía un viaje en bus,
a visitar a un amigo en Viña
y pasaron este video
que seguramente conocen
y se los quiero compartir.
Y en ese momento, me di cuenta
de que no estaba dispuesto
a sacrificar mi mayor anhelo,
que era la libertad,
por no animarme a luchar
más batallas con las crisis.
Después de todo,
no eran tierras tan duras.
Y es que, o moría ese día
intentando lo que quería hacer,
o viviría el resto de mi vida
queriendo volver a ese día
cuando decidí no hacerlo.
Hoy, después de cinco años,
construimos nuestra tercera empresa
ladrillo a ladrillo.
Y estamos en un rubro
donde conectamos a las personas
con la tecnología para crear
mejores ciudades y ciudades más seguras,
y nos encanta.
Y lo que más aprendí de toda esta tormenta
y de toda esta crisis
que casi me deja realmente en el piso,
fueron tres cosas.
Uno: que no estamos solos,
que en esos momentos
cuando nos sentimos solos y vacíos,
si solamente decidimos ver un poco
más allá de esa burbuja gris,
nos damos cuenta de que tenemos a alguien,
una persona, un amigo,
por último un extraño,
que está dispuesto a darnos una mano,
un empujón, o por lo menos una cerveza.
La segunda cosa que aprendí,
es que el dinero
no es proporcional a la felicidad.
Que sí está bueno crear empresas,
y de hecho, por eso hacemos las empresas,
porque queremos éxito financiero.
Pero es mucho más gratificante
si cada dólar viene acompañado
con esfuerzo, con pasión y con impacto.
Y tres, en las crisis creces.
Y si nos dedicamos a tapar,
enterrar, rechazar o postergar
lo que dentro de nosotros
sabemos que es verdad,
entonces estoy seguro de que ese conflicto
los perseguirá por el resto de sus vidas
hasta que decidan afrontarlo y ver
y crecer de él.
Todos conocen la metáfora
del elefante en el cuarto, ¿verdad?
Para los que no, imagínense que acá,
en todo este cuarto
hay un elefante gigante,
que solamente Uds. lo pueden ver,
y que ese elefante está cargado
de todos sus miedos, inseguridades,
sueños frustrados
y todo lo que nos atemoriza.
Ese es el elefante en el cuarto.
Entonces los invito a que se den cuenta
de cuál es el elefante en el cuarto,
es quizás el trabajo
que ya no los hace felices,
o la persona o su pareja
que ya no aman más,
o quizá la enfermedad que saben que tienen
que no la quieren aceptar.
Cuando antes hagan las paces
con el tamaño de ese elefante,
y decidan afrontar y abrazar
y agradecer esas crisis,
antes podrán sacar algo de ellas.
Y les hablo de películas,
y de que quiero ser William Wallace
y de estas analogías de la vida
porque siempre me gustó pensar
en mi vida con diferentes...
analogías y metáforas.
Por ejemplo, el de la película,
o de pensar que estoy en una pelea
de box donde todo es fuerza y resistencia,
donde tengo que entrenar muchísimo.
Pero tampoco me hace feliz,
o me hacía feliz pensar que mi vida
sean 12 durísimos rounds
con demasiados golpes en la cara.
Quizá la analogía,
y con esto ya voy terminando,
quizá la analogía que hoy me da más paz,
es la de pensar que estoy pintando
una obra de arte.
Y si en toda la presentación
vieron estos puntos quizás incomprensibles
de manera individual, para mí son momentos
que marcaron mi vida,
inflexiones grandes o pequeñas,
decisiones de decidir o de continuar,
de girar o de avanzar.
Puntos marcados con trazos, colores,
y cosas, y pinturas, y tonos,
y cosas que van armando
y van dibujando algo,
cuando yo voy viéndolo desde lejos
va dibujando algo que funciona.
Y es aquí donde les pregunto,
¿qué es una crisis para Uds?
Porque para mí, en realidad una crisis
no es nada más que una reacción
de nuestro cuerpo, de nuestra cabeza,
de nuestro corazón o de nuestro entorno
al hecho de dejar de construir
y de crear algo.
Porque sinceramente pienso
que no hay mayor desperdicio de vida
que vivir, o más bien, sobrevivir
sin crear o construir algo,
ya sea una empresa, una pintura,
una canción o una familia.
Entonces los invito
a permitirse tener crisis.
Porque pienso que la gente
no se permite tener crisis.
Y permítanse tener crisis
y conectarse con ellas,
siéntanlas, vívanlas, con el objetivo
de crear puntos, trazos y pinceladas
y colores, para que al final del día,
cuando Uds. empiecen a ver su vida
quizás desde un poco más lejos,
quizás muchos de Uds. en el (...)
de su existencia habrán construido
una obra de arte.
Y solo, solamente depende de Uds.
hacer que esa obra de arte
sea única, trascendental y digna
de ser colgada en algún museo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)